[Musique]
télé tu ne bouges pas tu as créé une
page facebook pour maya et surtout ne
nous ment pas ouais témoin c'était
facile mais il s'agit pas seulement
d'une page facebook en hockey mais
reconnaissez quand même que c'est une
véritable oeuvre d'art c'est vrai
j'étais fabriquer une nouvelle identité
t'as ton propre site web et tu donnes à
mort dans le social et du mali de faire
quoi pour mieux te fais ça pour ton
anniversaire
tu voulais tu voulais taper dans la
hotte alors j'ai pensé à cette [ __ ]
de sourire oui j'allais j'allais
utiliser ton pseudo porno mais tu te
sers jamais ton vrai nom alors mon
pseudo porno et telly challenge les
compagnies moi c'est validé
c'est brillant
[Musique]
tous les cadres de notre boîte sont
bardés de diplômes
la seule chose qui peut arrêter c'est
toi vous avez déjà fait un point sur
votre vie en vous demandant comment vous
en étiez arrivé là si vous choix avait
été différent seriez vous plus heureux
arthur a obtenu un master radio qu'il a
le meilleur profil pour ce poste lance
monsieur c'est moi
je voudrais vivre dans un monde où les
débrouillards sont aussi valorisé que
les intellos je les emmerde à qui tous
ces super diplômés avec leur jolie
maison leurs gosses qui ont des noms de
fruits et leur ascension du kilimandjaro
car si un coup de fil pour un entretien
d'embauché oh merde chez franklin clerck
votre cv m'intéresse business school de
word comment quand tu regardes son
incroyable page facebook la page
facebook
[Musique]
obama j'étais fabriquer une nouvelle
identité
tu voulais être au top niveau alors j'ai
fait de toi une cendrillon en mode cloud
c'est vrai que tout ça vient d'un
mensonge d'état techcrunch agent ma
belle quitter la championne à l'école
tqm jeune championne toujours bien de
thé une championne à lyon ce matin
ça va être difficile d'avoir un job à
votre âge
c'est ce qu'on verra à la bouille
[Musique]
ça va tu mets tout ce que tu veux sauf
ça on dirait madame doubtfire war c'est
mon bureau ito fils et un appartement et
des cartes de crédit au pas que tu
prennes sage des gardes tu touche pas
les jambes arquées sous peu tu vas leur
avouer la vérité après je peux y arriver
c'est un moyen vargas ce sont mes amis
de norton wharton en a fait beaucoup
d'humanitaires enfin on a sauvé des
baleines ne confonds pas ta vie sur
facebook avec qui tu es vraiment je vous
admire beaucoup dans quelques années je
voudrais tellement vous ressemble
[Musique]
tu as toujours été au top tu étais là
solaire en tout cas nous aimerions nous
implanter en chine est la seule employée
qui parle monde arabe
moi j'ai une idée notre veto parle
couramment mandarin
nous serons ravis de vous faire une
visite guidée attendant que la corse
aussi et d'abord retiré des trafics
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]